- Good morning Believe Nation.
It's Evan.
My one word is believe,
and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves,
and my sincere hope is
that if you see in yourself
what I see in you, you'll be
able to change the planet.
So to help you on your
journey, today's message is,
make today count.
Over to you, Nick Vujicic.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- I want to make sure
that every single day
that you are alive,
that you make it count,
and you take the sweeter choices of life
that God has given you.
Because I want to ask you right now,
if this was your last
30 seconds to breathe,
how would you be remembered?
Were you a giver, encourager?
Or were you a taker,
were you a bitter person?
Did you encourage people
to, in your actions,
in your life, did you help them,
or did you discourage them?
Did you take that time to
say, hey how're you doing,
and they looked to the ground and say,
oh, you know, I'm okay.
No, look at me, how are you doing?
We are here for one another.
This is the ministry.
This is Jesus.
This is the light.
And I want to tell you, I'm
sure that if any one of us
was at a road, and there
was a three year old kid
in the middle of the street sitting down,
playing with rocks in the
street, and a bus was coming,
and the bus was about to kill him,
you have plenty of time
to get up off your seat,
go save that kid.
Will you save that kid?
Of course you will.
You don't know his name,
you're going to save that kid.
You don't know his religion,
You don't know his sexual orientation,
you're going to save that kid.
Because, why?
We are the light and love and
the bridge to Jesus Christ.
We need to understand that it's
not just doing what we think
we need to achieve or have.
Some people think that things get easier
when you get married.
Uh uh, go talk to some married
people. (audience laughs)
Some single people are
like, oh I'm not happy,
but I know I'm going to be
happy when I get married.
Dude, if you ain't happy single,
you ain't going to be happy married.
Can you hear an amen?
(audience laughs)
Yeah, you guys already know it right.
You've got to talk that.
So what do you want?
How do you act?
Who are you?
Make today count.
Dream big.
And never give up.
- One of the most common
questions that I get asked
in a lot of interviews is
usually right at the end.
They say, do you have
anything else to share
with our audience?
Do you have anything else
to share, or anything else
that's on your mind that you
want to let us know about.
And I almost always will
default to, make today count.
Make what you're doing
right now really important.
- One final word for
influencers, just to go out there
and create their best
work and put their message
out there in the world.
- It's important, just
remember that what you're doing
is important.
Stop shrinking down, stop
waiting until tomorrow.
The work that you're
doing in this very moment
better mean something that
you want to go and show
your grandkids.
The more that you spend your
time thinking that this moment
right now is important,
the more you're going to do
important things.
I say that because a lot
of you guys are not taking
enough action.
You're not living up to your capabilities,
because you feel there's so much time.
Because you may know where you want to go,
you may have belief
that you can get there,
you may know all the steps
that you need to take
to be able to do that thing,
and part of that also, means
because you figured it out,
you don't actually want
to go and do the steps,
because the most fun part was
figuring out the strategy.
The hard part is actually
doing the execution.
And so, you know that it'll
work, but you don't want
to do the work, day in, day out,
to actually go out and do it.
And so, the mental exercise
was more the challenge,
than actually going and
building the company.
But, we feel there's a lot of time.
Okay, I could do it tomorrow,
I could do it the next day,
I could do it the next day.
You know, you can always push it off.
And it's not pushing
it off until next year,
or in 3 years, some of you do that,
but for a lot of people, it's
still just pushing it off
until the next day or the next week.
Challenge is, it still
doesn't happen the next day,
or the next week.
There's always a reason
why to push it off again,
and to push it off again,
and you know, it's nice outside,
so I'm going to go for a walk,
or you know, family issues
that you have to deal with,
or, or, or, or, or.
There's always something, right?
You're never going to
have the time to do it.
It's never going to have the
perfect moment where ahhh,
you know, like hours just
free up magically every day
of your life, to be able
to work on this thing.
And so you have to make it count.
Make today count.
If you had a practice
of waking up every day,
and whatever it takes
to get you feeling like
today is important,
whether it's reading a
book that motivates you,
watching an Entspresso
video in the morning,
whether it's remembering
that what you do today,
you want to show your
grandkids one day and be proud,
of like, I made this thing happen today.
Whatever that thing is,
that feeling inside you,
that doesn't just make
you think bold thoughts,
but that today matters.
That what I do today,
actually makes a difference.
What I'm about to do in the next hour,
Whatever you need to do to
get yourself in that mindset,
if you did that consistently,
your output would explode.
Because even as I'm saying
this, a lot of you will be
understanding it, but
you still won't do it.
And you'll still feel like,
you know that idea that I have?
I could do it tomorrow,
I'll still do it tomorrow.
I'll do it, I'll get it
done, I'll do it tomorrow.
And you've lost today.
And even if you do do it
tomorrow, you've lost today.
And so whatever you need
to do that every day,
you're thinking to myself, today matters.
What I create today matters.
It's going to last a
lifetime, it's that important.
This next video that I make
has to be that important.
This next product you make
That customer email
that you send out today
has to be that important.
I want to change that
person's life with this
customer support email
that I'm about to send out.
Whatever you do in your day to day work,
your day to day job,
your day to day business,
plus all the extra stuff
that you have to do to get
your company off the
ground, make today count.
And so the question of the
day today is, I'm curious,
what is it for you that
increases the importance?
What do you need to do on
a daily basis that will
help you really feel that today counts?
And hopefully by sharing
that, it encourages you
to do it more regularly,
but also gives ideas to
everybody else in Believe Nation of things
that they could try so
that they understand
that today counts too.
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm really curious to
see what you have to say.
And also, if you leave a
comment within the first couple
hours of this video going
live, you have the chance
to win one of our two daily prizes.
I also want to give a
shout-out to Laney Birk.
Laney, thank you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word.
It really, really,
really means a lot to me,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is, much love,
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- The first thing I want
you to know that success
is not a destination, it's a journey.
Think of success as a process.
Let me illustrate it
and explain it this way.
If you go to college, you work hard,
and in four, five years,
depending on what kind of degree
you're working on, and in today's society,
sometimes six or seven years,
but eventually comes
the day of graduation,
and you're all excited,
your family is there,
and your friends are there,
and you're there with your
classmates, and you've got your
cap and your gown, and you know
that there's going to be a time
in that ceremony where you're
going to walk across stage,
and the president, provost,
somebody's going to shake your hand,
hand you a diploma, congratulate
you, and you're going to
get off the other side, and
they're going to have presents
waiting for you, and
they'll be taking pictures,
everybody will be shaking your
hand, say congratulations,
today, you become a success,
you're a college graduate.
Now, my friend, you did not
become a success the day
that you got your diploma.
Now, what you did have happen
to you in that ceremony
is you got recognized for success.
The diploma is recognition
of what you have done
the previous four or five years.
You see, you were a success
in your freshman year
when you decided to not drop out of school
like some of your other classmates,
and decided to stick to it.
You were a success every
time you studied for a test,
and you were a success every
time you did a project,
or did a writing assignment.
You see, you were a
success all through school.
You're a success every day.
Success is a daily thing,
not a destination thing.
The day you got the diploma,
you just got recognized
for the success that you already were.
Now that's very essential.
Because so many times people
have a tendency to devalue
the moment, today.
What they do is the greatly
value the destination,
and so they kind of talk
about, well, when I get there,
or if I arrive there, or when I do that,
or when I accomplish this.
And they don't understand
that success is a daily thing.
And I'm here to share with
you that the secret of success
is determined by your daily agenda.
In fact, I wrote a book a few years ago
called Today Matters.
I'm passionate about that
book because what it does,
it helps you, it helps me to understand
that we make decisions and
then we manage decisions.
And too often we think,
I will make a decision,
for example, you're saying,
I'm going to make a decision
to be a coach.
Or, I'm going to make a
decision, you know what,
I'm going to make a decision
to be a public speaker.
I want to be a communicator.
Well, congratulations, you've
made a wonderful decision.
Coach, speaking, good decisions.
But that won't make
you a successful coach.
That won't make you a
successful communicator.
It's not the decision that makes you.
You've got to make the
decision by managing it.
And you manage the
decision on a daily basis.
In other words, what
you want to be tomorrow,
you've got to do today.
You visualize tomorrow,
that gives you hope,
and that's your motivation,
and that's your dream,
and nothing wrong with that,
you've visualized tomorrow,
but you value today.
What's that mean?
That means that what I do
every day is either getting
me closer to that vision,
that dream, that goal,
or it's really driving
me farther away from it.
You see, every day, we
are either repairing
or we're preparing.
You see, if I messed up yesterday,
guess what I get to do today?
Fix yesterday.
In other words, if I didn't
do the right thing yesterday,
what I've got to do today
is I've got to repair.
I've got to go back,
make amends, backtrack,
put the car in reverse,
put my life in reverse,
I've got to go back there.
I've got to repair.
Now, every day I spend repairing,
I'm not spending preparing.
Well, you see, we repair, when we fail
to manage the decisions that we've made.
We prepare when we, on a daily basis,
manage the decisions that we've made.
So your footprints to success
are really footprints of success,
because every step that is made and taken,
based upon the goals that
you have for your life,
and you're managing those goals correctly,
every step is the progressive
realization of success
in your life.
And by the way, you'll get the diploma,
you'll get the certificate,
but when you get that,
you didn't arrive, it just
is another step in preparing
you to reach your potential.
Each one of us should live
our life as if we'll never
learn everything we need to
learn, we'll never be able to
accomplish everything
we wanted to accomplish,
we won't be able to experience everything
we wanted to experience.
We should live our life every day hungry,
understanding that we
are to live until we die.
You see, I think success
can't be summarized in a
flippant degree or a program
or a diploma or arrival.
I think today if you
are learning to coach,
if you are learning to speak,
if you are doing the
things that are essential
to the decisions, and you are
managing those decisions well.
Can I say something to you?
Congratulations, you
are already a success.
Now, guess what?
Over time, it shows up.
You've heard the expression.
You've maybe even said it yourself.
You've heard the expression I'm sure,
I've worked all my life to
become an overnight success.
That's the way it works.
All of a sudden somebody recognizes you.
All of a sudden somebody
congratulates you.
You didn't get good at that moment.
You've been good for a long time.
It just showed up some day.